foreign
let's go out to Charlotte and talk to
Pam which is map backwards what's up Pam
how we doing
uh not much just hanging in there very
cool aren't we all right what's up
Edward ultimatum said I've been trying
with my husband who has a mental illness
oh ultimatums are never great they're
never good what ultimatums did you put
down
well uh so he has agoraphobia he's not
left our house at all for uh three years
and
it wouldn't be so bad except for like he
he also wants to keep me and our kids at
home yeah that's yeah yikes
um
we've had several showdowns about it and
I'm always the one who backs down
you've been in prison for three years
yes yeah you can't do that anymore
no your kids can't do that either
no
um
yeah you didn't make a call on this ASAP
there is
um so for those listening agoraphobia
it's technically classified as an
anxiety
disorder but agoraphobia agoraphobia is
initially a fear of large crowds right
when I don't know how I'm going to get
out of this situation and it
increasingly tightens your circle and
you may experience or imagine panic
attacks and then over time if un
untreated and undealt with and by the
way especially up front it's not a hard
um it's not a hard
um
Mental Health Challenge to to overcome I
mean it's pretty systematic but over
time untreated agoraphobics don't leave
their house they won't they'll they'll
shut the door lock the door they will
draw the curtains and then where it gets
really dire is when they trap loved ones
in the house too
and that sounds like where y'all are at
right
yeah well we're living this kind of
Half-Life where uh I'll go to my parents
house with the kids for a few weeks and
then we'll go back home and then he set
up we have a two-story home so he set up
like a basically an apartment with a
makeshift kitchen
you aren't even married
we are for uh two weeks every month and
a half
when he when he's done hiding from us
yeah yeah that I mean
that's not marriage
is he unwilling to go get go get help
if they want him to leave the house or
well it's just too hard say that one
more time I missed it
oh I'm sorry he's he's on attempt
s but for whatever reason he's always
backed out before so he's not getting
help yeah
and he's unwilling what is What is the
what is his narrative
uh
so he has OCD uh
uh he's going to he's gonna die and then
he's protecting us and that whenever we
do anything normal you know
go to the park we're risking illness
ourselves
I want people to hear that with an
agoraphobic especially somebody who's
man you throw an OCD on top of that
which by the way I'm I'm still in the
camp that those are
those are are similar I know there's
some neurological differences there but
I think the trajectory from anxiety to
OCD and back
um
are pretty tightly wound um are braided
together there
um but it is life or death so if you see
um like you're about to step in a
rattlesnake is about to strike you and
I'm talking to people who are listening
here
um not to you Pam but if you are about
to step on a rattlesnake or a car is
coming at you and it's 10 feet away
that's the feeling that that he gets
when he's about to go outside or when
you all have been at the park or been at
a grocery store and you come just be
bopping back in the house
um
how old are your kids
four and a half and two oh geez yeah
um
you have to make some hard calls here
quick Pam
and I know that you know that but I just
want to reaffirm you're not crazy and
your husband's worthy of being loved and
all that
but you can't do this much longer and
those kids cannot be penned up and
they're they cannot have their nervous
system wired and it already is down the
road especially for your oldest one that
they are somehow a contamination to
their dad
you know what I mean yeah yeah
and that they I mean it's it's for a
child's nervous system to be in the same
room or the same that's why covid was so
awful
for folks who had to go upstairs for two
weeks and quarantine their little kids
are downstairs and they just couldn't
wrap their head around it and that this
isn't just for two weeks this is for
ever in your home and my guess is this
this tends to escalate so it just slowly
moves is that how this has been going
for the last several years
kind of a better on a bell curve or it
escalated escalated and then you know he
he he got a little better he got a
little looser on things uh mostly I have
to kind of just say no and stand up to
them and so you know he's loosened up
quite a bit you know but
that that's um
anybody outside looking in wouldn't even
notice that he's he's loosened up and
he's gotten better
um
what's your relationship with your
parents meaning could you move in on a
permanent basis for a season
yeah yeah
here's here's the way I want you to
think of this
at the end of the day
not that your husband has chosen
agoraphobia not that your husband has
chosen anxiety or OCD
he has chosen up until now and I know
can also be a function of the illness so
I'm not cold-hearted and evil or all
that
but he has chosen to not
pursue care
and he hasn't had to
and so
um
at the end of the day you have to choose
what's best for you and your children
and you know as well as I do this
scenario is not sustainable and it's not
good for your kids
and it's not good for you
and so there will be a lot of grief
there will be a lot of guilt there will
be a lot of
um trying to figure out what comes next
and who knows what comes next
but this isn't about ultimatums this is
about health the health of you and your
kids
yeah
as an ultimatum when I talk to him about
it that's the way he does that's that's
how he keeps us his hooks in you
yeah you're not giving him an ultimatum
what you're going to do from this point
forward is do the things that you need
to do to stay well and whole
and that is I'm not going to be I'm not
going to be held a prisoner in my own
home I just won't be our children are
gonna go out and play with other kids
because they have to have that for
neurological development our kids are
going to go outside and get sunshine and
have different adventures and they're
going to have different tactile
experiences lateral horizontal uh
they're going to do all of these things
for their neural development not stay
locked inside this house watching TV
period
your dream and hope and I hope you
communicate this to him
my dream and hope is
that and I will go every step of the way
with you
if you'll have me
um my dream and hope is that you will
begin ASAP
to get the mental health care that you
need
because for agoraphobia for OCD for for
hyper anxiety disorders there's
significant help available
yeah
there is and for agoraphobia
specifically now he's he sounds like
he's really far down the road has he had
started the panic attack process yet
uh
not that not that I've seen he it's
mostly just like not sleeping is where I
see it like not a ability not to sleep
or I see it kind of
and I have I have a working hypothesis
that I may be crazy on but I have a
hypothesis that my anxiety did not get
super super bad like like irrationally
bad
I've always been just just
hypersensitive like uh able to read a
room able to know like oh there's about
to be a fight like I I it's all I've
been always since I was a little kid but
my anxiety didn't get out of control
until I spent several years taking
hypnotic sleep medications
because I was training
um mixed martial arts and from 8 to 10
pm I'd get home really late and then I
could just take this thing and it would
knock me out what I didn't realize over
time was I was not sleeping my body was
not getting restored of sleep I was just
unconscious through this medication and
I thought I had hacked the system right
and so
it was several years of not sleeping
well that I spun out
and so it may be and again we're talking
chicken or the egg here but I'm
wondering what six or seven weeks of
Deep
black hole sleep not hip not hypnosis
and not unconsciousness but of sleep
would do to his ability to think
rationally about what comes next
yeah he has to choose that
and let me be super clear I quit my job
we took a seventy thousand dollar
household income pay cut we moved I did
all kinds of things that were Radical
and insane at the time I turned down a
vice presidency I did a lot of stuff
because I've loved my wife and I love my
kids and I didn't want this I didn't
want this anymore
and so I tell you that to tell you it
might take huge sacrifices
and I'm here more than a decade later
and every single
inch of my life every single corner of
my life is different
yeah and I'm dude I'm no superhero but
my wife laid down some really firm
boundaries
and she was right to do so
what's your what is your hang up
uh
I I guess just lots of guilt for for
leaving him leaving a minute
staying in it doing anything positively
to help him
uh
at this point I don't think so
I don't either
what about the guilt you should have
towards yourself
or the guilt you should have towards
your kids that are seeing all this
so it's it's it's just
a lot of not feeling great exactly so
here's what I'm trying to get you
um I wrote about this in this new book
there's only a hard path
it's hard to to sit down with your
parents and say we're going to move in
for six months we're going to try a
six-month separation here
and you could tell your husband I'm not
interested in divorcing you I'm not but
I can no longer sit in this home while
you drown
in isolation and loneliness
yeah I can't I can't watch you do that
and I especially I'm not going to let
our four-year-old and two-year-old watch
you do this
and so I'm going to get them Community
I'm gonna get them sunshine I'm gonna
get them activity
I'm gonna go see a counselor because
this has been really hard on me the last
three years watching my husband slowly
suffocate inside his own house our own
house
um but I'm gonna live here for 90 days
for three months for six months
the moment you need a ride to go see a
mental health professional I will be
there
yeah right so this is an abandonment
this is at this point you've made you're
continuing down this path I'm gonna I'm
gonna choose to make sure that me and my
our two little kids are okay because
that's my job
yeah that's my job
and I want you to make sure your picture
of what a marriage is
oh let me go back you've got two hard
paths leaving will be hard
um being a single mom for a season with
your parents will be hard they'll
probably be some I told you so's and all
that some worst Daddy all that stuff
and staying in this current
psychosis
sitting in this dark house upstairs
where you're I mean it's just Madness
right when you say it out loud you're
like is this my life that's hard that's
hard too so that yeah you have you have
a hard path either way take the one
that's going to lead you towards healing
take the one that's going to be safest
for your kids
does that make sense you hear what I'm
saying that makes sense yeah
yeah nothing you've done up till now is
working let's try something completely
different and be prepared for the guilt
be prepared for his
um gaslighting and oh my gosh you
abandoned me you left me you're the
worst when I needed you most
all that stuff you know that's coming
yeah right yeah that's the stuff it gets
me of course you know so you know that
it is a person that's him saying I don't
want to actually
make the call to the professional I
don't want to call the fire department
to put this fire out I just want you to
sit with me and get burned to
yeah
yeah that's that's it
and I'm not gonna get burned anymore
I would go in that fire and get you if
it was to get you out and get you to the
professionals that can help
but you don't want that right now and
that's okay you're an adult you get to
do that I'm going to be heartbroken and
sick over watching my my the man I love
go through this and not accept anybody's
help
but also I'm not going to sit in the
fire with you anymore
right
and hear me say this agoraphobia it's
there's desensitization where they they
have you imagine things they have you
draw a picture of things and they sit
with you and they teach you some skills
and then there's usually panic attacks
involved and they teach you to work
through those but we're not talking and
then you you roll off into cognitive
behavioral therapy at some point we're
not talking a complex process out of
this
okay
yeah
um this is him choosing like I don't
want this life anymore
and I don't know what to do it feels
insane I feel like I'm gonna die all
those things are true I'm not saying
this is easy or trivial by any means
yeah yeah I I I I I believe he doesn't
want to get help because he's he's
afraid that getting helpful exposed into
what he thinks is going to kill him and
here's the deal in his mind he's exactly
right yeah how does he make money
oh that's that's the crazy thing he runs
uh three successful businesses from the
house with employees and everything none
of his friends know how sick he is he's
like super high functioning business guy
wow so yeah good for him good for him
yeah good for him
can't check the mail but you know
that was kind of a dig but I appreciate
it I like a good dick
yeah make six figures and can't go check
the mail but I mean that's that's a
that's a function right of geez Louise
yeah I hate that form I hate that for
everybody involved hit if everybody
involved um but let's let's go back and
he doesn't want to call 9-1-1
his house is on fire I don't want to
call 9-1-1 he just wants you to sit with
him and hold his hand and if you get up
and say I'm tired of getting burned
you're the bad guy you're not you're not
the bad guy
you're not the bad guy I don't think
he's a bad guy
and he has enough working in his life
that he has not been
forced with a face with an either or so
he's been able to keep his money coming
in his work from home his imaginary
leadership with employees virtual and
his marriage in some weirdly constructed
two weeks here you do this I'm going
over here you go over there weirdness
um
he's been able to keep all the plates
spinning and this is when you come in
and say I'm getting off I'm not on your
plates anymore I'm going over here until
you choose to get well
and he's gonna feel like he's walking
through hell and for his body he will be
and
you're worth it and so are those little
kids
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of building a non-anxious life this
is y'all's world
and this is what comes next
and these are the aspects when he sits
down after going through the exposure
therapy
um
he is going to
um have to create a new world y'all have
to create a new world together and this
is your road map building a non-anxious
life all of y'all are worth more than
this